e
[Musique]
il ya un fardeau qu'un homme peut
endosser
c'est là je m'instruis trucs
intéressants
le fardeau créé par ses actions passées
c'est un fardeau dont on ne peut jamais
se délester
tapis
c'est quand les cartes n'est ce pas je
suis pas aussi mal à meteghan et toi un
sponsor c'est ça ton boulot tu diriges
une écurie j'étais heures à la recherche
d'un quart temps
ayant été condamné à 10 ans de prison
j'ai appris à compter les cartes comment
vous faites
[Musique]
le poker c'est une question de patience
tchèque roland sur relance suivie et
sodas il se passe quelque chose tu sais
qui c'est c'est quoi son passé c'est là
qu'ils se basent tous les trucs
intéressants
et les mystérieux et je sais pas si
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose
vous vous souvenez de lui
j'ai fait des recherches je sais qui
vous êtes
vous ont envoyé en enfer vous leur avez
servi de bouc émissaire
vous voudrez peut-être participer à ce
que je vais faire et tu vas faire quoi
mettre les choses au clair
ça commence comme ça
on pense de furtives
qu'est ce que tu crois qu'on va faire et
s'agrandit
290 gretillat strode la porte devant et
la porte de derrière
faut que tu oublies tout ça
chacun de nous est responsable de ses
actes
est-ce que je cours à risque
peut justifier que nous avons fait
est ce qu'il est possible de savoir
quand on atteint cette limite